[Music]
hey minimizers you're getting ready to
watch some footage from one of the
minimalist live events if you'd like to
see us on the road head on over to
theminimalists.com to find a city near
you or you can watch recordings of all
of our live events over at patreon.com
the minimalists enjoy
howdy hey
patreon supporter here what's your name
oh man samia hey samir thanks for
supporting us what's on your mind
um you kind of answered this but i was
looking for a little bit deeper answer
um it's rare that you you see a duo like
you guys worked together for so long
um how do you resolve conflict
you know
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait is there any context that you
wanna no no context no context i just
give in as much as i can honestly
let's talk about what what do you mean
by conflict really because
um
and i'm not trying to put you guys in
this no no it's a good question i'll
talk about whatever you want to talk
about i'm just trying to i i just i
don't
the question presupposes that there's
conflict
no though so so for example like if you
know i've had businesses in the past
where i've had partners some of them
worked out well some of them didn't work
out well and i'm thinking how could i
have better uh headed off that conflict
rather than saying this isn't going to
work and throw my hands up in the air
and walk away
yeah i mean for me
in a situation like that like with with
a business partner i am in a situation
like that with a business partner
well i mean first off josh and i have
known each other since we were fat
little fifth graders that's totally true
so like we know each other very very
well which means we really understand
each other's preferences
we understand each other's likes and
dislikes and our little quirks and
whatever it is and the fact is is that
him and i or even me and tk i mean you
know these are two men that i really
really love so i go out of my way
to respect their preferences to respect
them and here's a here's so that's
number one is i go out of my way to
respect my friends family business
partners
the other thing because that is the best
way to get respect back by the way is
when you can go out of your way to
respect someone's preferences then
they're more apt to go out of their way
to respect your preferences if you're
starting from
a zero-sum game and you're like well i'm
not gonna budge until they budge i mean
that's
probably not not the right approach
but uh the other the other thing too
is oh man i totally forgot what it was
i got an answer but it's a short one i'd
love to hear what tk has to say about
conflict
okay go now okay
[Laughter]
well you know i think about this uh
bobby mcferrin song don't worry be happy
and don't worry that's not my answer but
there's a line in there where he says uh
in every life you have some trouble but
when you worry you make it devil
yeah we could
i love that line though because
it captures the idea that having
problems isn't a problem
what makes problems difficult is we
resent our lives for even having them
and so i think the first step to dealing
with any problem is embracing the
process of problem solving as a
spiritual practice to recognize that
problems are not curses
but problems are gifts not because they
feel good but because they make us
better and most of the things in life
that are for our good are the things
that challenge us are the things that
push us out of our comfort zones because
we not only attract things into our
lives based on our current state of
consciousness but also based on our own
innate impulse towards progress there's
a part of us that's in tune with certain
realities but there's another part of us
that's always striving to become a
better version of ourselves and
sometimes we attract people and
challenges into our lives that are
designed to help us get to that next
level of self-authenticity so when you
have a problem say you know what
i'm going to
be present in a state of non-judgmental
open-mindedness and attend to what this
problem is trying to teach me
second because you didn't just ask about
problems you asked about conflict which
presupposes that there's another person
involved i just read a quote the other
day by mother angelica that said being a
saint would be easy if it wasn't for
other people
that's the hard part right so when you
put the other person in there it gets
really difficult here's one piece of
advice i i'd give on that and i'll hand
it over to josh i would say
whenever you're trying to resolve a
problem with another person
don't try to convince the other person
that or
don't base your solution on trying to
get the other person to agree with you
on how much of an idiot you think
they're being
because if the other person needs to
agree with you on how much of an idiot
you think they're being in order to
solve the problem the problem will never
get solved
instead of focusing on their idiocy
step back and focus on what is the goal
because what is a problem a problem is
when you have a goal some kind of
outcome experience or result you want to
create and then there's some other kind
of thing that functions as an obstacle
standing between you and that desired
outcome that's what the problem is and
problems cannot exist if we didn't have
goals or outcomes that we want to create
and so use that problem as an
opportunity to take inventory of the
outcomes you want to create and say is
there an opportunity for me to let that
go
is there an opportunity for me to let go
of the assumption that i need that
outcome in order to be who i am that i
need that outcome in order to be happy
and also you can ask yourself
is there a way of going about that
outcome
that doesn't require me to be married to
the path
that i've become addicted to following
so can i let go of either the outcome or
can i let go of my one-dimensional way
of thinking about how to manifest that
outcome
i love that man it's like
it's like are you
are you is it
are you willing to let it go are you
willing to like plant your flag and die
on this hill yeah and so and thanks
because like that totally helped me grab
my thought back from the ether
[Laughter]
i don't take things personal like i try
so hard to not take things personal to
say i don't take things personal that's
like 99 true there are some times where
i catch myself in that and i'm like wait
why am i taking this so personal like
this is a problem that a friend has
and i have the opportunity to help them
solve it this isn't a knock at me
this is this is just an inconvenience
right now or yeah maybe it is a problem
arising so not take eve and i do this
with my my wife mariah who's here
somewhere thanks for coming mariah yeah
i i try really hard like to just not
take things personal because sometimes
you know sometimes i'll be in a mood
myself
for whatever reason
and i might have a certain
energy that i'm projecting or an emotion
that i'm projecting
and it has nothing to do with anyone but
me
and it's like i will have to sometimes
say like hey i know i'm being kind of a
crap head right now i see kid in the
front audience so i'm gonna try and not
cuss this whole
podcast
you know i'm i know i'm like being a
jerk right now but please don't take
this personal it's it truly is not you
it's me i'm just like a little messed up
right now so not only do i not take
things personal i also try to go out of
my way to like make sure other people
aren't taking things personal from me
what's your name man
samir sameer
all conflict is self-conflict
i think that um we get so caught up in
thinking that um
the problem is outside of us
and then whatever the other person's
behavior is is making us mad
but the anger arises within us and that
person could behave in that same exact
situation or quote unquote worse with
someone else with a completely different
outcome the anger would not arise within
them so anytime we feel frustrated
anytime we feel upset
any time we feel offended
and we get offended recreationally now
that's never someone else's problem it's
always my even if they've done something
to intentionally try to to offend me
to upset me
it's up to me
and so
the reason that we often get offended is
because we've been we've been told a lie
that things are good or bad or right or
wrong the other day ryan and i were
talking about this very specific thing
and he told me i was being complacent
about that thing
and
a knee-jerk reaction for me would be
like well no i'm not but the answer is
yeah i am and what's wrong with that i i
felt like it was yes it is perfectly
appropriate for me to be complacent
about this thing and so yes you're right
i understand that i am
and
because ryan wasn't saying well you
should be another way
and i think the way the reason we have
very little conflict between us is
because we love each other but
most of us don't understand what love is
we say love is what
there's a bit in the book where it's um
i love my wife but i also love burritos
well neither one of those things are
love when we talk about it because when
we talk about loving burritos what does
that mean i really like this thing
that's great
well when i say i love my wife what does
that mean well most of us say i mean it
means it it's an attachment i'm attached
to this person
i need you we've been told those lies by
pop songs for a long time now right i
need you in order to be happy
you complete me
nonsense
i'm already complete without you but you
do augment or enhance my experience of
life to love someone
is to see them for who they are without
trying to change them and so the reason
ryan and i don't have a ton of con
conflict is because
i'm not trying to change him
and he's not trying to change me to try
to change someone
means you hate who they are
you could tweet that podcast sean
yeah
yeah you had me at hello man oh man
especially when you were like cause you
were looking at me you were like you you
don't i'm completing myself but you are
at me t.k you incomplete that's right
but we love you still
man you know it made me think when
you're saying that josh how
whenever there is some type of
disagreement or misunderstanding or you
can call a conflict wherever you want i
look at it as an opportunity to like
understand you more yeah and and through
understanding you i understand
other people
and so
when you escalate a conflict you are
losing that opportunity to have a deeper
understanding for who whatever it is
whoever it is that you're having that
conflict with
so going out of your way to understand
is always going to it's just always
going to be more meaningful well the
opposite of that is what
self-righteousness
and so that's the reason that we want to
be right in a situation in order for me
to be right someone else has to be wrong
these are just cultural imperatives that
we've made up oh i'm right there for
you're wrong it's like maybe we just
have a different understanding of this
thing help me understand your
understanding and even at the end of
this if i don't completely understand it
doesn't mean that i'm right it just
means that i don't understand
you know one thing i'll add to that is
we've kind of been conditioned to think
about power as something that depends on
getting other people to see reality in
the same way as you and so
if if i can't convince you
to
believe in my idea or if i can't
convince you to vote in the way that i
vote well then i'm fundamentally
powerless because all power is
democratic right certainly there's no
such thing as the creative power of the
individual which can be expressed in a
way
that's independent of other people's
disagreement well
most of the good things that we get in
life comes from that kind of creative
power there's this beautiful moment and
i'm going old school here but it's in
one of the matrix movies where uh
morpheus he's this very esoteric
character who believes in a lot of
strange things and he's arguing with
this very pragmatic man and telling him
what he thinks the solution is and he
gets very upset and he says damn it
morpheus not everyone believes in in
fairies and oracles and all of these
things not everyone believes as you
believe and morpheus looked at him and
he said fortunately my beliefs do not
require them to
power isn't the ability to out debate
people power isn't the ability to use
argument or logic to make people feel
pressured to see things the way that you
do power is the ability to look another
person in the eye and say
you don't see it the way that i do
that's okay i give you permission to be
who you need to be because i know how to
express myself authentically and
creatively in spite of your disagreement
i love you anyway and i'm gonna do me
anyway and our lives will intersect
organically at the place where our
deepest gladness meets that's power amen
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free
you